This is Enceladus, an icy moon revolving around
Saturn.
Unimaginably cold, this white orb looks very
peaceful.
Except that it’s actually home to ice volcanoes
that spew frozen chunks of slushy magma at
800 miles per hour.
Cryovolcanoes are similar to the ones we have
on Earth, just swap out the molten lava with
sub-zero water.
A cryovolcano forms when thick layers of ice
get heated by gravitational forces.
Then pockets of water are created under the
moon’s icy shell.
Pressure eventually builds in these liquid
pockets, and when a crack on the surface opens,
icy plumes erupt!
Those plumes are so cold, that if you were
standing next to an erupting ice volcano,
you’d turn into a block of ice.
Inside the plumes magma are a mixture of carbon
dioxide, water methane gas, and ammonia.
These ingredients have scientists excited
-- because these elements are the crucial
building blocks for life.
But what kind of organism could possibly survive
in Enceladus’s ice cold waters and in pitch
black darkness?
It won’t be space dolphins and narwhals,
but if anything, it could be like the extremophiles
at the bottom of our oceans - the odd looking
creatures that feed on microbes near underwater
vents.
So to reiterate, huge cold dangerous ice volcanoes
exist and they might birth alien life.